he was so addicted to it that he felt he
needed to buy the platform listen to
Sam's take on it and I think you'll see
how we're connecting it to everything
else I me look at what Twitter has done
to elon's life right it's just you know
Elon used to be a friend you know he
somebody I knew reasonably well
um you know his engagement with Twitter
has
been catastrophic for him as a person
from my point of view I mean it's just
it's clearly a compul compul Ian he was
so addicted to it that he felt he needed
to buy the platform um but it is a you
know his use of it has been so
irresponsible and uh produced such
forget about the harm he's produced in
other people's
lives how and nothing I'm saying now
relates to changes he's made to the
platform I mean that's that's a separate
thing that we can talk about you know
I'm I'm I've always been agnostic as to
whether or not he could actually improve
Twitter as a as a platform and he may
yet wind up doing that but I'm just
talking about the way he has personally
used it as a user of the platform and
the way he's interacted with people and
boosted signal boosted
massively um the profiles of anonymous Q
andon lunatic trolls right I mean he's
he's been completely Cavalier in who he
interacts with all the while knowing
that anyone he boosts suddenly gets you
know a million followers and has a
platform that they otherwise couldn't
imagine having um so I look at him and I
think okay if if someone of his talent
who has so many other good things to do
with his 24 hours in any given day uh is
is this derailed by this platform you
know is this is using it this
compulsively to the
obvious degradation of his reputation in
most circles that so interesting his
obvious degradation in most circles that
count now that sounds like quite a quite
an elitist statement uh my position is
obvious the guy has bought this thing
because he has been defending Free
Speech it's what he spends all day long
talking about on the platform and
putting up polls on what their policies
should be and should we allow Alex Jones
back on or not etc etc right should we
allow Donald Trump back on etc etc he
didn't have to do it I think it's a
pretty dim view to say he bought Twitter
because he was addicted to Twitter like
he just bought a little toy he bought
something that is allowing us to see
more Truth Now does that mean that
sometimes there might be more mean
people on there and more mean trolls and
they're going to say bad things about
Dave Rubin and a whole bunch of other
people of course but they existed there
before uh so the idea I mean he used the
word catastrophic that elon's purchase
of Twitter Twitter if you even if you
were to just look at the events of the
last three months the videos that we've
been able to see the horrific video
and and all of the barbarity and all of
the stuff that would not have traveled
as easily on other platforms because of
they would have been censored and they
wouldn't have fit the narrative and all
of those things it's like he's allowing
more truth to get out there but I think
a certain set of people who really
believe in the system they don't want
that much truth out there right they
don't want that many voices out there as
Sam is saying he wants a certain the
certain circles in certain circles
people don't like Elon that much I think
the people like Elon that's the thing
so it's interesting because Elon is sort
of like Bill Mah right like he's just
kind of like a common sense rational
liberal you may not like what his voting
record is or anything else but I think
you could put say an Elon Musk and a
Bill Maher in the same camp of we're
trying to figure it out more speech is
better than less speech Let's be
skeptical and then I think you could
take another bucket and that would be
the Seth McFarland Sam Harris bucket and
it's kind of like no we'll figure it out
for you guys and our corrupt
institutions are kind of well we won't
even call them corrupt but our
institutions are kind of good even
though they're woke and we're always
fighting the woke and everything else so
that seems to be the
Divide